okay welcome back everyone from lunch
I'm going to suggest we make a start
just to keep on time and so the theme of
this afternoon session is networks over
time and if you know 80 you'll recognize
that I'm not in fact 80 I'm just
imputing for him and my charge was to
say a few words about the session and
how the talks relate to one another and
just to give you some things to think
about so here we are sort of the middle
of the afternoon of the third day and
here is the schedule for the afternoon
we'll have two talks first Laden will
speak and then sofas and these talks are
sort of theme together in a way that
I'll talk about then we'll break for
coffee 1432 1500 and then it's back on
again with streaming and sketching
algorithms and so we'll have two talks
again and then at about ten minutes 24
will do about we've budgeted for about
40 minutes of wrap-up discussion so I'll
will work to keep things roughly at the
time and so we're starting a few minutes
late but otherwise things will run
pretty much the time and we'll we'll
collect that overlap in the coffee break
so where are we in the context of the
workshop much of the preceding couple of
days has been devoted to the following
problem given one instantiation of a
network of one realization of a network
which we're probably going to model is
random are often go to model is random
how can we make inference from this one
object sometimes we're interested in
inferring the structure sometimes the
structure the serves is sort of
ancillary information on which we
condition but nevertheless we're often
working from a single snapshot and of
course most people who have worked on
reward problems will tell you that
that's not always the way things are so
many networks are of course dynamic they
can be dynamic in many different ways we
can have a sequence of network snapshots
over time we can have experiments that
yield replication data where
an experimental condition has been
varied or time has passed we can have
diffusion spreads cascades over networks
if you think about something like public
health HIV is an epidemic it diffuses
over a sexual contact Network and that
of intravenous drug users who share
needles etc but over the years public
health intervention probably actually
shapes the structure of that network so
we can even have processes that evolve
dynamically on networks and change the
structure of the underlying network at
the same time as they evolve so the big
difference from from a sort of
statistical point of view released an
asymptotics point of view is that we now
have two dimensions to the analysis and
or the number of nodes as well as
teatime and so the obvious question here
is can we come up with models that have
interesting and sensible limiting
behavior as either or both nnt 10 toward
infinity and that's something we're
going to hear about in the first couple
of talks in the session both explicitly
and sort of implicitly lurking under the
surface it's worth thinking about the
fact that oftentimes we simply integrate
time out if you look at something like
the Enron email data set and you just
look at the the set of anyone who's ever
emailed anyone else you're implicitly
integrating at a time right so that's
the simplest thing you can do there's
also the time-honored tradition of when
doing so think of a scan statistic over
the data we don't have to be local in
space we can also be local in time and
that's going to feature in both of the
first two talks it's also interesting to
think about what is the context of an
edge mean in a time-varying network we
might think of instantaneous edges as
being more like points and a point
process and that's something that won't
feature in these talks but it's maybe
we're thinking about and then of course
one can make this arbitrarily
complicated and we'll hear sort of bits
and pieces of that but but of course in
order to actually compute anything at
the end of the day the models have to be
sort of able to be handled so there's
two themes to the session
first two talks are really about models
for network evolution so the basic
paradigm is that we have a sequence of
snapshots of an evolving network and we
have to think carefully about the
dynamics of this evolution and get to
grips with the sort of transient nature
of these edges I will hear about that
both in the context of sort of sparse
precision matrix estimation and then in
the in the context of some experiment
empirical work at Facebook the second
half of the talks after the coffee break
will switch and we'll think instead
about models of computation okay so the
idea here is that in order to work
effectively with very very large graphs
with the unbounded amounts of data if
you like we need sort of new algorithmic
primitives and new paradigms right and
so sketching and streaming are two ways
to think about this problem you can also
think about them as relating sort of
statistical efficiency of representation
or compression and a computational
efficiency and that's something that
Mike Jordan has alluded to it at various
points in the recent past so the last
thing I'll say there is just that in
both cases there are significant gaps
between theory and practice and it's
often called out in the slides of the
speakers so you know pay attention to
pay attention to where those gaps are
they may be something that we want to
talk about at the end of the session so
as I said the first two talks are about
sequential observations of an evolving
network soma Laden is going to pause it
some procedures for you know elicit some
models and posit some fitting procedures
for these time evolving networks and you
can think of this work as in part being
Beeman's inspired by the sort of sparse
estimation paradigm all right so some of
you may be familiar with the literature
on covariance matrix shrinkage and
Thresh holding this has a similar sort
of flavor one puts down essentially
penalized likelihood models enforces
sparsity which gives us something that's
consistent with the notion of sparse
networks and in a way we go and the
interesting thing to think about their
maybe is
can you identify the right time scale or
the right rate of change of the
underlying process are we talking about
smooth dynamics in which case when doing
is a really natural thing to do kernels
or are we talking about abrupt changes
in which case you're almost doing like
you could do you could think of this as
a nonparametric change detection problem
you know the network is somehow
stationary for a while and all of a
sudden it shifts regimes and you want to
detect that transition point the second
talk surface is going to ask from the
point of view of data how the choice of
temporal aggregation affects the
underlying analysis so specifically this
again I think comes back to correctly
identifying sort of time scales of
evolution whether we integrate time out
whether we use a sliding window that has
a long time constant or a short time
constant can have a fugitive effect on
the downstream analysis and sophis is
going to talk specifically about the
problem of tracking communities that
evolve over time so communities can
evolve over time and a node's membership
in a particular community can also
change and I would like to ask us to
think about you know could one reduce
this to a question of propagating
sufficient statistics right there's a
Kalman filter asked representation there
might be something there and again we
come up to this question of you know if
an edge is transient then what is an
edge our interactions repeated and
instantaneous or they really
representing flows of information do we
want to treat these things as discrete
points or do we want to think of them as
flows and that touches on several
different literature's so after the
coffee break we'll switch over to
computation sketching and streaming so
this is really as I said about coming up
with ways to analyze very very large
data sets when we're under computation
communication and storage constraints
potentially and you can play this game
in a number of ways andrew is going to
introduce the topic and he's going to
talk about which summaries we can and
can't compute and things like and poly
log n space there are some things we
know that we can do
some things we know previously that we
can't do and this is a kind of like
almost like a semi streaming paradigm
because we're allowing ourselves a
little bit more than just order in space
right and then finally to round out the
session sesh is going to ask a specific
question in the streaming context which
is how do we count triangles right so
we're talking about a scenario where we
start being concerned when things
stopped working when the graph has I
don't know a million nodes or something
right so we're we're talking about
orders of magnitude above and beyond 10
to the 6 right so he'll introduce
specifically triangle counting in the
streaming paradigm explain sort of how
his result works at talk about some
extensions to multi graphs the basic
thing they're being that when you derive
these algorithms you assume that edges
are never duplicated and that's never
the case and or not often the case in
practice and then I really like the
slides of several points where he says
we have a theorem and then it doesn't
work well in practice at all so there's
a lot of focus here on kind of closing
this gap between theory and practice and
that's something that we've seen a come
up again and again over the past few
days so without further ado we will go
ahead and switch over and malad enough
first up and so why don't you come on up
and we'll do our thing